[Musica]
vi siete mai trovati di fronte ad un
problema così complesso a sentirvi
incapaci di risolverlo come se venisse
sopraffatti dalla situazione quasi
paralizzati
spesso è questa la situazione la
sensazione che si prova quando ci si
trova ad affrontare i problemi legati
alle questioni ambientali
quantomeno questa è la sensazione che
provo io circa una volta alla settimana
in quei momenti ci sembra tutto così
difficile che qualsiasi cosa facciamo
non è mai abbastanza per fare la
differenza ea quel punto se un problema
non possiamo risolverlo perché sprecare
energie per provarci
con questo in mente finiamo per non
agire perché ci sentiamo di non poter
essere attori di una possibile soluzione
eppure anche i problemi più complessi
possono o nel caso dei problemi
ambientali devono essere risolti se
vogliamo sopravvivere
stasera proverò a raccontarvi di come
noi di giles stiamo provando a
risolverne e uno
durante il mio primo anno di università
per una strana coincidenza di algoritmi
e social mi sono trovata tra le mani un
articolo in cui si diceva che nel
mediterraneo tra le coste della toscana
e della sardegna c'era una
concentrazione di micro plastica è
superiore a quella presente nelle isole
di plastica del pacifico
avevo già sentito parlare delle isole di
plastica però le avevo sempre pensate
come un problema lontano non mio e
invece avevo davanti agli occhi la prova
del contrario
e da questo semplice articolo è iniziato
ad unire i punti da quando ho 14 anni
passo le mie giornate in acqua per fare
quando aveva iniziato la situazione era
ben diversa perché era addirittura
strano trovare dei rifiuti in mare o in
spiaggia mentre oggi è diventata la
normalità uscire dall'acqua con la muta
piena di pezzi di plastica che si
recuperano tra le onde eppure non avevo
capito la gravità della situazione
finché non ho trovato questo articolo
quando si passa così tanto tempo a
contatto con la natura e con l'ambiente
diventa impossibile rimanere fermi
immobili davanti a situazioni di questo
genere si prova quasi un urgenza un
bisogno di fare qualcosa di ridare
qualcosa al mare ed è per questo che è
nata shire hodge air viene da auchan
giles sono le correnti oceaniche
circolari bensì a spirale che sono ormai
note per intrappolare i rifiuti nelle
isole di plastica
il nostro obiettivo è quello di ripulire
l'oceano dai rifiuti
per farlo abbiamo cominciato da quello
che già sapevamo
antonio che il fondatore insieme ad
andrea aveva già avuto un brand di
abbigliamento sportivo
quindi abbiamo usato le sue conoscenze
per fare dei costumi in plastica
riciclata e recuperata dal mare
in questo modo si utilizza come risorsa
quello che ha considerato soltanto un
rifiuto e anzi lo si inserisce in un
nuovo ciclo produttivo incentivandone il
recupero dal mare
sicuramente è una soluzione che può
funzionare ma non vi sembra che manchi
ancora il punto della situazione
è vero che i costumi sono pensati per
essere riciclati in modo da non andare
mai a pesare sulle risorse naturali per
nuovi cicli produttivi
però ci sono comunque tutti gli aspetti
legati alla produzione alla spedizione
poi tutti quegli aspetti di moda che non
volevamo avere alla fine il nostro
obiettivo è quello di togliere i rifiuti
dalle maree e se questo è il nostro
obiettivo perché non andare
semplicemente a toglierli quindi ci
siamo soffermati su quali siano le cose
davvero necessarie per togliere i
rifiuti e alla fine
focalizzandoci proprio sul problema
abbiamo capito che quello che serve è
molto poco perché basta qualcosa o
qualcuno che passi molto tempo in mare e
poi una tecnologia che permetta di
raggruppare i rifiuti sollevarli e
portarli a terra sembra però uno di quei
problemi quasi irrisolvibile per
l'appunto una di quelle cose che ha
bisogno di una tecnologia rivoluzionaria
mai sentita prima
qualcosa di mai visto prima nel tempo e
nel mondo o forse no
per questo motivo abbiamo deciso di
rivolgerci ai pescatori a chi conosce il
mare più di tutti
con loro attiviamo dei progetti di
phishing four letter
per andare letteralmente a pescare i
rifiuti
in pratica quando lo riescono ogni
giorno a pesca tengono a bordo quelli
che sono i rifiuti che rimangono
normalmente incastrati nelle loro reti
ea fine giornata quando rientrano porta
una terra non solo il pesce ma anche
questi rifiuti che a terra vengono
appunto rendicontati pesati e poi
smaltiti correttamente
in questo modo riusciamo anche a tenere
traccia di quelli che sono i progressi
nella nostra attività che condividiamo
con tutte le persone e le aziende che
decidono di supportare la nostra
attività attraverso la piattaforma già
air ci finanziamo infatti con dei
progetti con le aziende oppure tramite
la vendita dei prodotti sul sito e in
questo modo riusciamo a supportare
economicamente i pescatori che decidono
di aderire al progetto e le
organizzazioni non governative che ci
supportano
quando si fanno progetti con le comunità
come nel nostro caso sono infatti
importanti due aspetti il primo è il
fatto di avere una relazione continua
con le persone che si fanno a
coinvolgere per questo motivo dobbiamo
appoggiarci a partner locali soprattutto
per quei progetti che abbiamo in brasile
in indonesia dove noi non possiamo
essere fisicamente
e in secondo luogo bisogna sempre
ricordarsi di quelle che sono le
peculiarità del posto e delle persone
con cui si va a collaborare anche se la
soluzione che abbiamo trovato è una sola
e può essere applicata a qualsiasi
contesto non può scendere dall'alto
semplicemente bisogna adattarla alle
persone e al luogo con cui si va ad
interagire per questo motivo in italia
dove pescherecci sono più grossi e vanno
a motore
i pescatori recuperano i rifiuti nel
momento stesso in cui vanno a pesca così
da ridurre l'impatto ambientale dei
trasporti mentre in brasile in indonesia
dove i pescherecci sono piccoli sono
anzi delle lance a remi e dove il costo
della vita è molto più basso
riusciamo addirittura a supportare
pescatori a pagarli per dedicare alcune
giornate o comunque parte della loro
giornata
unicamente al recupero dei rifiuti
in questo modo riusciamo anche a dare un
po di sollievo alla fauna marina locale
ovviamente questo è lo stato di come
sono ora i progetti però iniziare non è
stato così semplice
diciamo che l'essere umano a questa
formidabile capacità di complicarsi
sempre la vita anche quando le cose
potrebbero essere molto più facili
infatti aprire i primi progetti in
italia ne è stato un esempio ci siamo
dovuti confrontare con la burocrazia con
i suoi tempi e soprattutto con le leggi
nazionali
basti pensare che fino un po di mesi fa
c'era una legge che impediva ai
pescatori di riportare a terra e rifiuti
perché erano considerati rifiuti urbani
questa legge sembra già di per sé
assurda ma è ancora più assurdo se si
pensa che dall'altra parte c'era una
legge che vietava ai pescatori di
buttare in acqua rifiuti quindi i
pescatori che recuperavano qualcosa si
trovavano nell'assurda situazione in cui
non potevano rigettare in mare rifiuti
perché ovviamente era illegale ma non li
potevano riportare a terra perché
dall'altra parte facendo lo avrebbero
rischiato una sanzione economica e
penale
ora per fortuna questa situazione nei
mesi scorsi è stata risolta e l'italia
ha recepito una direttiva che finalmente
permette ai pescatori di buttare di
nuovo in mare i rifiuti
per fortuna no per fortuna permette ai
pescatori di riportare a terra i rifiuti
e in questo modo rende anche molto più
semplice per noi attivare nuovi progetti
e supportare anche pescatori in questa
loro nuova attività
non solo noi ma in realtà lo permette
anche ad altri enti tanto che c'è
proprio un progetto di phishing four
letter che sta partendo vicino a noi in
campania perché alla fine le soluzioni
così come i problemi non sono poi tanto
lontani
quindi noi abbiamo deciso di dedicarci
alla tutela del mare è un problema
complesso enorme che abbiamo deciso di
scomporre in problemi più piccoli
abbiamo preso quello dei rifiuti già
presenti in mare e ci siamo dedicati a
questo la nostra prima soluzione quella
dei costumi funziona
funzionava funziona tuttora però non era
abbastanza centrata sul problema quindi
abbiamo dovuto ragionarci ancora
focalizzarci di più sul problema
eliminare tutto il superfluo per poi
renderci conto che in realtà è la
soluzione era già portata di mano perché
c'erano già i pescatori ci sono già alle
reti e come tutto quando ti rendi conto
che hai bisogno di poco è tutto già
portata
sono cresciuta con una storia che mi ha
regalato mia mamma quando ero piccola un
uomo camminando lungo la spiaggia vedeva
da lontano un ragazzo che in riva al
mare si chinava a raccogliere qualcosa e
lo rigettava in acqua l'uomo incuriosito
si avvicino al ragazzo e avvicinandosi
si rese conto che sulla spiaggia in riva
al mare c'era una distesa di stelle di
mare che erano state portate a terra
dalla mareggiata della notte prima
il ragazzo che stava raccogliendo una ad
una per rigettarla in mare l'uomo si
avvicina ancora di più al ragazzo e gli
disse ti rendi conto che le stelle sono
troppe perché il tuo gesto conti
qualcosa
il ragazzo senza neanche alzare lo
sguardo si chinò a raccogliere una
stella e mentre la gettava in mare gli
disse per questa sicuramente conta
qualcosa
a distanza di anni ho scoperto che la
storia non finiva lì perché altre
persone vedendo il ragazzo dal lungomare
lo raggiunsero e insieme riuscirono a
salvare tutto
grazie
[Applauso]